-Welcome back. Welcome back.
No, please, after you.
Oh, after you.
No, after you, of course. Yeah.
It is so great to see you, bud.
-Thank you.
Everybody should have that
experience once in their life.
Walk into a room
with The Roots playing.
-Exactly, yeah.
-There's nothing like that.
-How does it feel to be in front
of an audience and a crowd?
I mean, they love you.
Come on, bud.
-Hi, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Last time we were
with each other together
was almost 11 years ago.
Does that --
-It feels like 20.
-It feels like yesterday.
But, I mean, a lot has changed.
We're dads now.
-That's right. Congratulations.
-Congratulations to you. Yeah.
-Thank you.
-How does it feel?
-It's the greatest.
-Yeah. How old are they?
Are they around
the same as mine?
-6 and 7. Yours are...
-8 and -- Yeah, 7 and 8, yeah.
-Okay.
-My girls are a little bit
starting to not laugh at
every joke that I tell.
-Oh, okay.
-'Cause they used to be
my number-one fan.
I'd do anything,
they'd be like...
[ Laughs ]
..."Fantastic."
Now they just sometimes
don't react or
I get the eye roll or something.
You're like, "Did you just
roll your eyes at me?
I mean, it's cute,
but don't do that."
Yeah, yeah.
-My youngest has a real power
move where she'll, like --
Here's an example.
We got to work in France,
and so we went to The Louvre
and we saw, you know,
"Winged Victory."
We saw "Venus de Milo."
And we're standing
in front of the "Mona Lisa,"
and she turns around
and she goes, "This museum?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I said --
-Only kids.
-I said, "Why?"
-Yeah.
-And she went,
"Because it is not good."
-Yeah. N.G.
N.G., man.
-And then the real power move
is, sometimes,
she'll turn around
and she'll just go...
The thumbs-down walk-away.
-Walk away.
Oh, that's a fantastic move.
-It's like
Roman-emperor-level shade.
-Just walking away with
the thumbs down is a power move.
I want to ask you
about this photo.
-Okay.
-I just want to ask you
questions about it.
I saw --
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It broke -- It officially broke
the Internet.
-Well, you know, the Internet's
been trying to
break me for years.
-Yeah. And they finally got you.
-So they gave me
no other choice.
You are Ken
in the new "Barbie" movie.
And this is fantastic.
Were you surprised by the
great reaction this photo got?
-I was surprised how, you know,
some people were kind of
clutching their pearls
about my Ken,
as though they ever
thought about Ken
for a second before this.
-Yeah, you feel like
he's underappreciated.
-They never played with Ken.
-Underappreciated character,
Ken.
-They never played with Ken.
Nobody plays with Ken, man.
-You don't really play with Ken.
-Did you play with Ken?
-Um...
-Exactly.
-No, I didn't play with him.
-It was available.
-And yet...
-He stayed in the toy box.
-He's an accessory and not even
one of the cool ones.
-He's an accessory of
Barbies, yeah.
She's got the camper.
-The house.
It's unbelievable,
what she's done with the house.
Have you ever put together one
of those houses, by the way?
-I tried.
-I want to sue Mattel.
I had -- So mad.
I was like, "Oh, my gosh.
This is the craziest thing
to put together ever,"
the Dreamhouse.
And that's it.
We have the house
and now we live in it.
It took so long.
But you know what?
There was a thing in
"Vanity Fair."
They said they think they know
why you chose the role of Ken --
because you have
a love of Jean jackets.
-Oh.
-And...
That's you throughout the years
loving the jean jacket.
I do like a good jean jacket
if I can rock it.
But that is not the reason
why you chose Ken.
-Did you bring me on your show
to denim-shame me?
-Yeah.
-Is that what this is?
There's no denim shame
in my game, man.
-No way, man. I love your denim.
-I love denim.
-No, I want to set up this story
because it made me laugh.
You're like, "No, the reason why
I took this role --"
You got a call from
Greta Gerwig -- or an e-mail.
-Right.
-From Greta, who's a great
actor, director, writer.
And she offered you
the role of Ken.
-Yes.
-And you went out in
your backyard and you were --
You know, you want to
think about it for a second.
You go in the backyard.
-Best script I've ever read.
I walk out in the backyard.
And do you know where
I found Ken, Jimmy?
Facedown in the mud
next to a squished lemon.
-And this is the photo --
You took a photo of it.
And this is a sign.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a sign
that you got to do this movie.
The utter disrespect.
-I texted it to Greta and
I said, "I shall be your Ken.
For his story must be told."
-Yeah, his story must be told.
I want to hear this guy -- What
happened to the situation here?
I know you're doing press for
"The Gray Man,"
but people were asking
you about the "Barbie" movie,
and you -- Then they go,
you know, "What is it about?"
And you go,
"Well, Ken has no house,
you know, "No home and no job."
And they're like,
"Is this a drama?
Is this a sad --"
-Those are not plot details.
Those are just
objective facts about Ken.
-It has nothing to do
with the movie.
The movie is not about
Ken having no house or a job.
-No. Those are just --
That's the Ken life.
-Yeah, that's just the Ken life.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I just wanted to
straighten that out
for anyone that's going like,
"That's not what the
'Barbie' movie is about."
It's going to be --
What a cast, by the way.
I cannot wait.
Everyone you can think of.
It's going to be
funny and awesome.
I want to talk about
"The Gray Man."
-Okay.
-Dude, talk about action on top
of action on top of action.
-And then more action.
-And then some sneaky action.
-Yeah, and they snuck
a little action in there.
-They snuck
-Yeah.
-Do you know,
in most action films,
there's like four to five action
moments, big action moments?
-Yeah.
-This has nine, Jimmy.
-That's four and five.
-Wow. That's five added
action sequences.
-We pack the action.
-Yes, you do.
-It's action-packed.
And you've got my man,
Chris Evans, as well, in this.
And, yeah, look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, I must say, you're rockin'
some pretty awesome facial hair.
You got the goatee.
-Oh, yeah.
-He's got the mustache.
-Yeah.
Our facial hair
had different acting styles.
His mustache went to
the Stella Adler School,
and my goatee was Meisner.
-Meisner, of course.
-And it's electric on set,
but it's --
Off camera, it is trouble.
-What is "The Gray Man" about?
What do people --
What should they expect,
besides action and fun?
-It starts with action.
-Mm-hmm.
-Then you find out this
character --
They pull him out of prison
to be a spy,
but he doesn't want to be
a spy, Jimmy.
-Of course not.
-He'd rather be at home watching
Netflix, like the rest of us.
-Yeah, exactly. Of course.
-But he can't.
He has to.
They're forcing him to do it.
The only way he gets out...
-Is to go back in.
-...more action.
-Yes! That's exactly right!
-Amazing cast,
amazing characters,
and then we close it out with
so much action.
-There you go.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ryan Gosling in
"The Gray Man."
Take a look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give me the gun.
[ Tires squeal ]
♪♪
-Get down!
You're in my shot.
-You gave me an empty gun?
-The shells were coming, okay?
-Huh?
-The shells were coming.
You -- You ran away too fast.
-Then you need to say,
"Hey, wait. That's empty."
-No, it's assumed.
-I assumed it's loaded,
so I run after the guy.
-Who throws a loaded gun?
-I asked for a loaded gun.
-No one throws
a loaded weapon, okay?
Are you coming?
-Ugh!
-I'm going to bleed out
while we have this conversation.
Can we just
unpack this somewhere else?
-Yeah. Let's just unpack this
somewhere else.
That's what I'm talking about
right there.
Ryan Gosling, "The Gray Man,"
everybody.
Thank you for being here.
-Thank you, man.
Should we talk about it now?
-Is it grossing you out?
-Should we talk about this?
-Wait. Hold on a second.
[ Music starts, stops ]
It's gross.
Is it grossing you out?
-What's going on with
the nail, man?
-My nail was --
Yeah, I hit my nail.
-What's happened?
-I have a black nail.
-Yeah.
-You know what happened?
There's a screen door.
I slammed my pinkie
in a screen door.
I was holding the screen.
It was one of those screen doors
that go like...
[ Hisses ]
And I go, "Oh, that's nice."
And then, all of a sudden,
it went, "Whap!"
And so it got me.
Is it bumming you out?
-It looks fungusy.
-It's black.
It's not fungusy.
It's just black.
[ Audience groans ]
-You know, I have --
-Sorry. We --
-Having two little girls,
I have...
Just saying, if you want --
I mean, it is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Shall we?
-Will you do the honors?
-It is -- I mean, Jimmy, you're
in the public eye right now.
-This is --
-There you go.
-You did a great job.
-Thanks.
-Look at that. Look at this.
It's like nothing ever happened.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is fantastic.
You did a great job.
Ryan Gosling, everybody.
"The Gray Man" begins
streaming on Netflix tomorrow.
When we come back, Ryan and I
are doing something fun.
Stick around.
♪♪